pourquoi le coronavirus inquiétant alors
que la grippe est plus dangereuse
ça c'est la grosse question c'est une
excellente question effectivement
puisque on sait la grippe ça peut aller
jusqu'à 1 millions de contaminations par
an entre 5 et 10 mille morts par an en
france
le coroner virus les début de l'épidémie
mais on vient de franchir le seuil des
100 personnes contaminées quatre morts
apparaît dérisoire alors pourquoi ces
deux poids deux mesures d'abord la
première chose elle ne devrait pas
exister c'est à dire que de la même
façon pour la grippe
on devrait mettre en place ces systèmes
d'isolement les personnes malades de la
grippe devraient tous porter un masque à
éviter de sortir de chez eux ne pas
aller au travail les enfants ne
devraient pas être à l'école pour éviter
d'aller dans les lieux de rassemblement
de prendre les transports en commun de
la même façon que on le préconisent
aujourd'hui pour le sahara skov de ce
nouveau coronavirus alors pourquoi cette
différence
et bien parce que je pense qu'on a à
faire quelque chose de nouveau
la grippe on la connaît la grippe on
sait qu'un vaccin existe on en a
tellement l'habitude que finalement elle
ne nous fait plus peur à tel point que
les gens ne se vaccinent pas autant
qu'ils devraient toutes les personnes de
plus de 60 ans toutes les personnes avec
des maladies respiratoires
toutes les personnes avec des troupes de
l'immunité qu'elle soit acquise induite
par des traitements ou autres devraient
être vaccinés tous les membres du
personnel soignant devraient être
vaccinés mais comme elle ne fait plus
peur cette bonne vieille grippe on
connaît depuis la nuit des temps et bien
voilà on relâche un petit peu les
les méthodes de prévention est un peu
par égoïsme ne se fait pas vacciner pour
éviter d'avoir la douleur au bras et la
fièvre le lendemain et d'être un peu
patraque pour quelque chose on n'a
peut-être pas besoin on la trappe à tous
les ans il est vrai là on a affaire à
quelque chose de nouveau alors il ya
quand même un principe de précaution
c'est vrai qu'au début on annonce est
une maladie beaucoup plus mortel qu'elle
ne l'est réellement n'est peut-être plus
tôt à 1 2 % de mortalité
néanmoins ce virus peut encore muter
on ne sait pas et voilà c'est quelque
chose de nouveau et tout ce qui est
nouveau je pense qu'en matière de santé
et surtout d'épidémie ça fait peur
bon moment